bene tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video su rocket league il giochino
dove se forse signore vuole assieme
possiamo arrivare a champion ma è una
cosa molto difficile e solo con stef
anche e qualche mia compagna e oggi the
scatolo due ritrovamenti lari gli altri
lo ritengo per il prossimo video così
compenso e faccio le views tattiche
youtube ha proposto apriamo prima colora
roque quello dove teoricamente trovato
un po meno ma meno power l'attenzione
una cagata incredibile è una pianta non
è un acquario no ti prego fatelo vedere
appena arrivi vedere cosa più critiche
abbiamo visto per una macchina è proprio
quello con tolaro ragazzi dai che sfiga
la quasi rosso ho trovato la dominus con
i puntini che schifo giochiamo va bene
ragazzi alla boccettina in the head è
let's go by broschi bravo dai per usi ma
non andrà mai in porta perché sabato c'è
mike scioscia t e lui attenzione
affinché non smentisce vuol dire che lui
tanto non annunci non abbiamo fatto
riscaldamento siamo dei maniera mirata a
giocare su ubi siamo pazzi esempio
esatto ci sarà un motivo questi fanno 70
partite in casa e una in competitiva e
invece noi no
attenzione però non è esploso no che
occhio attento e va in porta che stanno
arrivando da allora il dribbling sul
retro ora che non si fa pregare per
l'attenzione incredibile vado io a
spingere la palla mamma ultimo così
mezzo che non è male e porca vacca primo
rimette la intro prova ci faccio una
roba strana dio
eccolo bellissimo come mi fai sognare
come di festeggiare bellissimo che sei
fatto ma va là dove di fatto non tornavo
una roma così bella fenomeno bellissima
hai fatto un caos pazzesco bellissimo
però sono stato mai va bene sapevo che
spunti il giocatore non sembra perfetto
scappa scappa scappa
mamma mia che ci sei
perché se no io l'avevo lasciata è mai
chi m un altro meglio
ma è che parlava di regolare è stato un
misunderstanding nostro come peccato
diamo un bel mezzo se vuoi di mamma mia
me l'aspettavo bonino non lo fa guarda
non l'ho fatto
no non ci credo non credo che possa
perfetto la riprendo io tiravo no tiro
io no tornate indietro visita portale
nava ma com'è possibile come ha fatto a
buttarla in avanti da noi che arriva
dalla nostra parte come diavolo va bene
va bene va bene va bene non è vero in
cornali bravissimo la prova ritoccare
ancora sei un fenomeno è la tocca a mai
però la barca materia no sono un bronzo
4 ok dare fastidio e niente
viene prevista non previsto che aspetta
volevano una zampa tra chi non ne sono
visto niente la bella finta e non è male
però è palo però è palo perché noi non
abbiamo il loro la loro fortuna per non
essere non fendi friendly amando la
mamma mia
beh visto niente oggi occhio che qua
tirano aiuto bravissimo provando la pira
lei userebbe mai uno contro uno è il
bello anzi mi aspetto al traguardo
ti aspetto attenzione attenzione
attenzione queste buono che stiamo per
loro però niente si è allungata troppo
il mike scioscia ecco noi e noi e non
avevo visto questo un oleodotto vale el
82 volte non c'è l'altro no perché siamo
stati certo si segnala so è incredibile
occhio bravo anche presentati da sicuro
nome tirato fuori non riesco a
controllarla si no perché c'è l'altro
guido che cosa ma dai laliscia tensione
davanti non ci riuscirò mai quello che
vuole toccare non vivranno tritati tutti
e due tira aspettano giornate gattino la
teca è proprio la stefan e che gol
bellissimo e lo dico anche orsina tac
era difficilissima dovrebbero forse non
poteva proprio perché anche con tutto il
turbo del mondo era troppo angolata
bravissimo un'altra più carica ragazzi
che mi arriva stati solo due ma edizione
risalire altra partita dalle voci non
sembrano forti ma dalla festa metterà
una vita reale lisma tremosine steel non
lo scopo era per cercare di incentivanti
in qualche modo studio perché la
partenza non è male e vuol dire che
l'abbiamo già vinta ok bene ok perso
perché contano invece il controllo forse
riesco
va bene va bene di un assalto questa
però mi abbia fatto come se non ci fosse
un tuorlo land quindi niente occhio
tranquilla vo
non fa niente lo snodo anch'io no non
l'ho esploso non è vero l'altro è un
passaggio perfetto bellissima donna che
leonzi del bellissimo tra l'altro
perfettamente non poteva entrare in un
altro modo se non così perché io ero lì
prepararla e lui l'ha tirata ancora più
in alto per non farmela prendere e dei
traversari non poteva entrare se non ti
viene è incredibile con la tua al
dettaglio
l'ho beccata aveva una palla gol occhio
però forse tira bravo si sono sì però
non so se arrivo si arrivò bravo bravo
prof
lo stefano e che mi fa l'assist ore 11
130 di punteggio e martin garics si vola
l'importante è fare gol chi se ne frega
di come entra anche entrare mentre sei
storto al contrario non vale la palla e
non è neanche libro che la stava pure
togliendo un bellissimo ma la riprendono
in credito di as a ritocchi mezzo si no
si tira gol dai berretti
ti prego poi certo c'è noi non siamo gli
avversari da me non entra e giusto così
aiuto aiuto cosa sia vero
porca vacca che sfiga immonda così è
successo ho sbagliato io non ho capito
come premesso che da tempo vede avevano
niente colpa mia
cobham pato porco demonio è perché
eravamo sotto pressione quindi faccio
prendere dal panico scusa ma son bravi
questi però si possono battere
sì sì sì ti ala occhio che questo è un
matto
bravo john se per caso andavo in porta
questa è invece ci fa lo stesso porca
vacca e il 45 attenzione che non è male
attenzione non è male penso che dire del
canale che si basano solo crossare però
la prima da fanno talmente bene che
venire a quel punto sia in un segnale se
la tiri vale il 2 a 3 dic operiamo
subito lavoro ma dai
però tutto giusto neanche per sbaglio
prendono la traversa
niente neanche verso fi quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto un pittore una
sconfitta ma vabbè è stata comunque una
bella partita
sono state le belle partite scegliamo
prossimi episodi vediamo dove ci porta
il cuore dove ci porterà in champion non
penso proprio di cazzo non si fanno in
stile di aggancio dove mi piace e
ragazzi
[Musica]
no